Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to HoloTalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show enjoyed in over 42 countries throughout the world.
And now here's this week's show.
Hello, John, how are you?
It's Frank Defratis.
Hey, Frank.
Good to hear your voice.
Good to hear your voice too.
How would you like to start off?
I mean, when I visit your site, I've known of your site for a long time now.
I I find it an amazing resource not only for the work that you've done over the years in holography, but also for some of the priceless photos that you have on there as well, historically speaking.
Oh, good.
Well, I'm glad you like that.
Yeah.
I've been very fortunate to uh to have been a witness to some of this, I think, would be the way to characterize it.
Mm-hmm.
When you were growing up, you lived in Oak Ridge, right?
Correct.
What what was your connection with Oak Ridge in those days?
Was that just a town or were you with a military family or something?
No, uh Oak Ridge was, you know, created during World War II as part of the Manhattan Project.
And um uh a lot of young people um converged on the town from all over the United States because they had either special skills or because they were uh local folks that that needed work.
And um as a result, uh well well, John Fairstein was one of the results of that collaboration of people.
Um and um after the war, um in addition to the uh Manhattan Project facilities, uh the Oak Ridge National Laboratory had been created, and uh uh there was a tremendous amount of research going on there uh and continues to this day.
It's one of the premier laboratories in the in the world.
That's where you f saw your first laser demonstration was at the Oak Ridge National Laboratory.
And and and that was just that that was a real epiphany for me.
I I think I was like uh eleven or twelve years old, and my father took me down to the high school auditorium where um they uh di this was in like nineteen sixty-three or sixty-four, shortly after the first helium neon laser had been demonstrated.
Yeah.
You don't happen to remember the early manufacturers.
Was it uh division of Hughes aircraft that was making the first Heaney lasers in production, do you know?
Gosh, you know, I don't remember.
I remember uh Joe Don and Yeah, I remember those too, yeah.
And and some of those folks that uh got early early start and one of the companies that a very early starter was uh called PSR uh incorporated here in Oak Ridge, and they made uh lasers for uh research.
And um this was the same group of guys, uh Percy Statz, Henry Morgan, Miles Skidmore, and George Werner, uh among other ones, who put on this demonstration at the high school.
Okay.
And it was astounding.
I mean, no w we had never seen laser light.
And they had they had it bouncing all around the auditorium.
They were at that time they were even transmitting sound over the laser beam.
Wow.
And uh, you know, this was a laser that they had made.
They they had their own glass blowing shop and uh own facilities and these guys just they when they read the original papers, they were all over it and immediately uh began building their own lasers and and of course they wanted to demonstrate it to the community so it was just astounding.
I mean and for me a little kid, you know, to see this was was uh I never forgot it.
I can I can clearly remember to this day sitting there and looking at that beam and the speckle pattern.
Just just astounding and uh you know I continued I I've I've known those guys uh ever since uh um so and and in fact uh an interesting little sideline story is that uh when Dr.
Xiung from the you know now famous Lake Forest uh uh college um was actually um employed at ORL uh shortly after that and for some reason uh all of his paperwork hadn't been completed yet so he was kind of twiddling his thumbs and these guys said well listen you know you might want to play around with this thing uh these lasers and this new thing called holography so uh Dr.
Xiang spent spent a year at O R N L with sort of free access to uh some big granite tables and lasers and uh and that's where his holography career got started was right here in Oak Ridge.
No kidding.
Yeah.
Now that is an interesting side story.
And uh and to this day, uh I I think one of those guys that had demonstrated that laser to me, Henry Morgan, uh he and uh and Dr.
Xiang are still I'm I'm assuming they're still in communications.
Yeah.
I haven't talked to Henry in a long time.
Let me ask you this.
Do you happen to remember during the demonstration what applications they mentioned the laser was used for presently and future applications?
Well, they they uh y you know it's been a long, long time, nineteen sixty-three, but uh I I distinctly remember them transmitting sound over the beam, which uh you know was amazing to everyone.
And I think they also discussed uh the idea of uh of uh transmitting uh you know, not only sound but data and you know, and and other information.
Um at that time I don't think holography had been uh what what had been popularized, so I don't think that that was part of the discussion, but uh certainly uh transmitting data and uh sound was.
Yeah, it must it must have been very close to um or very shortly after Emmett Leith uh at the University of Michigan with the uh first uh laser transmission hologram up there.
Correct.
Yeah.
So after that, what did you do?
Did you still continue to have an interest in lasers, and that's what eventually led you out to San Francisco in the seventies?
Um well, I had uh attended uh college in Ohio and a couple of my classmates were uh Lon Moore and Randy James, who have later achieved a prominence in philography.
Oh yeah.
And we uh we uh all three of us went to San Francisco where our college had started a branch program out there under the auspices of the University Without Walls, which was a great idea.
Uh the idea being that the university would just have an office and that we would our classroom would be the entire community.
Mm-hmm.
So uh uh They were actually just starting that in Philadelphia when I was in high school with uh high school without walls as well.
Oh yeah, okay.
Well well I thought that was a great idea, and so I jumped on that opportunity and uh and Lon and uh Randy James uh uh also came out there and uh in the course of our our studies, uh Lon uh was introduced to Lloyd Cross and well Lloyd came to the college and put on a little demonstration of uh holograms, and what he did was he had these big uh I guess they were about one foot diameter cardboard tubes that were maybe three or four feet high.
And he put the laser down in the bottom, a little one milliwatt laser, and then uh and put a lens on it, and then put the hologram on top of the tube.
So it made a very nice little simple display.
And these holograms were just terrific.
They were four by five and eight by ten transmission holograms that were uh illuminated by this laser down in the base of the tube, and they were just crystal clear.
They were they were completely noise-free, just beautiful holograms.
Laser transmission holograms are beautiful holograms.
Yeah, and they had tremendous, of course, tremendous depth, and you know, and and it's uh it's exactly like uh in in your interview with my good friend Steve Province, where he where he says that you have this small epiphany when you see this.
And that's exactly true.
You see it and and your pupils contract and your whole body becomes rigid, and you're just astounded by what you see.
And even today, when I see a hologram, it's uh has a similar effect.
Well, I was just completely captivated and uh and immediately signed up with the school of philography to take the basic holography class.
And there I met uh of course I already knew Lon, and I met uh Fred Untershare and uh Gary Adams and Lloyd Cross and Michael Kahn and all of the the denizens of the school of philography and was introduced uh Lloyd conducted a lecture in the back of the school of philography that uh described some of the physical principles behind the whole thing, and then uh Lon or Gary or or whoever would would come out and give us some instruction in uh in the basic techniques of sandbox holography.
And what they had done is they had built uh uh sort of a four by eight foot box out of uh cinder blocks and filled it full of sand, and this was based on an idea that uh Jerry Pethick had uh had introduced and then we mounted all the optics on the ends of uh P V C pipe and and stuck it in the sand and arranged it and then after you had everything arranged you let it settle for thirty minutes or so and then shot your hologram.
Well you you just can't imagine something more exciting than that.
Especially in nineteen seventy three.
Yeah when you see your first hologram it's just I mean, you know, they were very primitive, you know what I was doing, but gosh it was so exciting.
And uh you know and then and then they there was all these things that began to develop out of there.
You know, they began to experiment with uh I remember Steve Benton came and showed a uh a rainbow hologram.
Well immediately everybody at the school started scrambling around scratching their head trying to figure out well how did he do that?
And uh within within three days Lloyd had had completely figured the whole process out and w and and we were shooting rainbow holograms down there.
And uh then it was just a couple of steps away to the multiplex holograms and uh you know I was kinda I kind of uh I I can't say I was an active participant.
I sort of lurked in the whole thing but uh I got to witness a little bit of the the first camera, the first multiplex camera and then some subsequent developments of that.
So just fascinating.
Certainly nothing wrong with just being a witness to all that happening for the most part.
It's the I would compare that to someone saying, well, all I did was just sit on the floor while the Beatles were recording.
Well, I've I I'm very fortunate uh to have witnessed all that.
So uh now an address keeps popping up into my mind tonight.
Maybe you can resolve this address for me.
What does Shotwell Street mean to you?
Well that's where the school of Is that where that was?
Okay.
Four I think it was four fifty-four Shotwell Street or something like that.
Uh you know, it was this enormous uh warehouse that was kind of divided into two halves, and on one half was was the holographic studio, and there was uh oh, I don't know, three or four of these uh uh sandbox setups uh that allowed them to teach classes, and then they had an experimental uh uh uh a little dedicated what they call the holographic camera that was used to make uh reflection holograms.
Then there was another little area where they were building up the multiplexer, and uh then on the other side uh the folks that that that were active, um like Gary Adams and uh Pam and uh Lloyd and Michael and all those folks lived on the other side.
They kind of had little loft areas where they where they lived.
Pam is the woman that eventually wound up in Lloyd Cross's KISS, right?
Yes, yeah.
Yes, exactly.
Pam Brazier.
And uh and and there were just any number of people that floated through this this warehouse in you know and Well what what type of people were they?
Were they artists, were they scientists?
Were it's kind of a combination that was some of them were very technical.
Um I I remember there was a guy there that worked directly with Lloyd and and they Lloyd had created this method of uh stretching a membrane off of a across a speaker and then attaching a small mirror to it and producing light shows.
I remember that.
Well this guy I don't remember his name but he was kind of a uh you know what what we would call nowadays a geek.
You know, he was sort of a very technical person and very uh able to concentrate uh you know his energies on this particular problem.
And then there were other people like uh Pam and and other folks that were more artistic and uh you know had very creative ideas about how h holography could be applied to uh to the visual arts and and just uh just a whole mix of different folks in there that uh all of them just brilliant energetic and uh you know this i it was it was a fantastic environment.
Oh that's incredible.
I guess I'd uh also like to point out something this whole you know from my point of view from what I've seen holography is as much uh uh uh a social a kind of a social dynamic uh as it was a scientific or engineering or artistic uh media because it attracted so many uh diverse people with different ideas and uh you know kind of a uh very free thinking at that time and it and you got to remember that the political landscape at that time was we were in in the midst of the Vietnam War we had entered into uh into a deep recession and uh it there was I mean there were just tremendous political forces swirling around this cavern called the the School of Vologney so uh you know it w it was it was quite a quite a scene.
You eventually started your own company out there as well, right?
Yes we did.
Uh uh Lon Moore and uh Randy James and Fred Huntersher and I uh and uh Nancy Corglione and her friend Dave um we started uh and and our friend uh Constance Lubin uh started what we called celestial holograms which was based out of a house in the Richmond district of San Francisco and we found a house that was sort of isolated from a lot of traffic and had a big basement in it.
And uh we built uh an enormous five foot by ten foot uh uh sandbox that was had on a huge concrete slab and I think the idea there was that we wanted to have long uh throws for our beams so that we could uh produce some eight some good quality eight by ten masters without having to uh col purchase collimating engines and optics.
And uh Michael Kahn, uh my my dear friend Michael Kahn built us a laser and in typical Mike Kahn fashion it was a bare bones laser that uh you know all the power supply was just completely exposed and uh to you know the high voltage was just right there and ha long long tube with a manually adjusted uh mirrors on it that we had to constantly tweak those mirrors to get get it into single mode operation.
But we uh we started immediately producing some holograms and we'd take 'em down to the waterfront and sell 'em on the street and uh oh that was so exciting because people you know tourists would come and they'd see that and they'd never seen anything like that and and we'd go out on a sunny day, we didn't take any lights or anything.
We just used the sunlight and it it the the reaction of people that came to see these simple holograms was just fabulous.
I mean they were delighted.
So uh Well you know something John I I bet you would have the same reaction today.
I believe we would I bet you would I believe we would it it's just it's it's like Steve Province says when you see it you have a small epiphany.
And uh you know it's it's almost a small orgasm when you see a visual orgasm when you see these things.
Mm-hmm.
So we uh we chugged away and uh produced holograms and tried all different kinds of things and you know we were under a lot of uh all of us were under a lot of personal financial pressures and we were all very creative and independent minded people so eventually the the thing uh you know kind of we we kind of separated but uh uh you know the spirit kept going.
I think Fred went uh went on and uh wrote his famous book and went on and did just some tremendous uh things and of course Lon started whole business and and was very successful at that and Randy uh later worked with Steve McGrew and then took over that whole uh uh operation of holographic mastering and I think he's continues with his Pacific holographics.
I'm not sure of the name I think Yeah I was just uh on his website the other night.
Nancy uh Corglione of course went on and did uh did some tremendous work and collaborated with Michael Kahn on some vacuum deposition stuff and I'm not sure what happened to her friend Dave um but but all everyone went on and and continued on and was successful in the in their various spheres of holography.
So um uh that was a very seminal little company that's celestial holograms.
Where did people envision this all leading?
Did you think ten years, twenty years?
Who what was the general thought as to where all this was going and where it would lead well I'm not a good person to ask that question because um I I was sort of in the moment and uh I didn't have the uh the ability to think very far out but i the the initial excitement um that from from the very first moment that I saw Lloyd's holograms at at there at Antioch West propelled me along for about fifteen or twenty years.
Um I think uh some of the other folks, I think Fred and Lon and Randy had a longer range vision about what where they fit in uh into holography and what they wanted to do with it.
And uh, you know, I think that they each in their own personal way uh were were were able to achieve their goals.
Um I sort of was blowing in the wind for about fifteen or twenty years, I'd say.
Well, I I certainly can appreciate your uh outlook of living in the moment because I I strongly believe in that myself.
So we're I feel two birds of a feather when it comes to that, even today, every day.
As long as you take care of today, tomorrow t usually takes care of itself.
Yeah.
With that in mind, what we're gonna do is l let's take a quick break because what I'd like to do is put this into two parts because we're coming up on to uh close to twenty-five minutes, and I like to keep the file sizes manageable because we do have a lot of listeners that are overseas on dial-up connections, and I try to keep the file sizes small.
So let's take a quick break and we'll come back and uh for those of you who are listening to it this week, next week we'll have uh part two.